Привет! Это пятый урок модуля. В прошлом у нас на Figma появились Warframes, рамочные макеты и сайт-мэп.
Сегодня тот же Figma файл мы закладываем в дизайн-систему. Variables, фундамент, базовые компоненты — всё одним прогоном.
Прежде чем запускать директивы, что-то там смотреть, давай разделим то, что у нас есть, на три сценария.
Сценарий первый: дизайн-систему у нас нет. Мы стартуем с чистого листа, и нам нужен вот этот старт, какая-то база, от которой можно будет отталкиваться.
Сценарий B: мы берём уже готовую дизайн-систему. Есть огромное количество библиотек: ShedCN, Material, Carbon, Gravity UI и так далее.
Любую из них можно использовать как точку для старта с уже готовой базой компонентов. Как это сделать, мы тоже посмотрим.
И сценарий B: если у нас есть дизайн-система в компании. Ты уже где-то работаешь, есть дизайн-система, она живая, поддерживается команда, и вам нужно научить агента работать по ней.
Знать, какие компоненты есть, какие варианты, как они называются.
Сегодня разберём все три. Нам понадобится для этого всего две директивы: DSBaseline и DSCAN. Они будут, как обычно, в описании к этому уроку.
Итак, прежде чем запускать директивы, нужно понимать, что мы вообще пытаемся здесь создать.
Дизайн-система FIGME - это слой Variables + компоненты, которые на эти Variables ссылаются.
У меня три разрозненных артефакта, какие-то токены, переменные, компоненты, которые потом как-то между собой перекликаются. Нет, у нас одна структура, поэтому собираем мы всё в одном уроке.
Итак, по поводу Variables и переменных. Здесь у нас иерархия из трёх слоёв. Первый слой - это примитивные токены или глобальные.
Конкретные значения цвета, размер отступа, например, Blue500 и его кодировка цвета, Gray100, 200 и так далее.
Ну, я думаю, все с этим знакомы. На всякий случай объясню вообще, как это всё работает, потому что знаю, что всё равно не все этим пользуются, а это важно.
Итак, первый слой примитивный - это просто палитра, без смысла в продукте, без привязки к чему-то конкретному.
Второй слой - это смысловые токены или семантические. Что это в продукте?
Например, Surface Action Primary - он ссылается уже на конкретный цвет из палитры, на Accent 500, Blue500 и так далее.
Название этих токенов, ну, в принципе, их создание, образование, опирается на смыслы, на роли, на то, для чего они конкретно созданы.
Например, у нас есть какая-нибудь обводка границ, есть фон в кнопках, для акцентных кнопок он будет всегда одинаковым, какого бы там, например, размера она ни была, у неё фон будет задаваться через такой смысловой токен, для этого они и нужны.
Важное уточнение, в них мы не пишем какие-то кодировки цвета, мы привязываемся к нашей палитре, обычно вообще не меняется, может быть только дополняется, а вот смысловые токены, их можно уже перепривязывать к разным цветам из этой палитры.
Для этого они не существуют, для того, чтобы мы быстро могли внести какие-то изменения.
И третий слой, это компонентные токены, локальные значения внутри компонента.
Например, Baden Primary BG ссылается на Surface Action Primary.
Этот слой нужен только если у компонентов своя тонкая логика.
На стартовых семи компонентах, которые сегодня мы будем создавать, обычно этого нет, поэтому появляется это позже.
Всё это разделение служит для того, чтобы у нас всё следовало одной конкретной системе, и если нужно что-то поменять, то сделать это можно было максимально быстро.
Вот можем посмотреть, как это может выглядеть в реальном проекте.
Есть у нас какие-то нейтральные цвета, видим, что здесь всё описано кодировками цвета, и максимально простыми названиями всё здесь указано.
Grey 700, 500, 300, 200.
Здесь у меня ещё разделено на Brand и Accent цвета, но так делать вообще не обязательно, достаточно просто в одном месте всю палитру собрать.
И другой слой, уже семантические токены, они могут также подразделяться на Background, Foreground, то есть заливку на Border, цвета для обводок и так далее.
И здесь мы можем увидеть, что у нас уже они все ссылаются на конкретные цвета из палитры, на глобальные токены.
Вот, например, Natural, Grey 700, здесь у нас тоже используются всякие Grey, например, тут 50.
И если у нас создаётся какая-то карточка, у нас уже есть семантический слой Background, Default.
Мы знаем, что по дефолту у элементов цвет вот такой, нейтральный, белый.
Поэтому, когда эта карточка создаётся, здесь сразу через семантический токен этот цвет задаётся.
И делается это уже на уровне агента.
Он сам это всё понимает и собирает как нужно.
Итак, когда и какой сценарий мы выбираем из этих трёх?
Тут у нас всё определяется тем, кто контролирует дизайн-систему в первую очередь.
Ну и в остальном, для каких назначений она вообще нужна?
Первый сценарий нам подходит, когда никто не контролирует дизайн-систему.
Ну, имеется в виду никто, кроме тебя, да?
То есть ты сам с ней работаешь и больше никто с ней не взаимодействует.
Это стартапы, микрокейсы, обучение, то, чем мы сейчас занимаемся.
Собираете стартовую свою дизайн-систему с нуля под продукт и расширяете её с появлением новых экранов, новых путей и так далее.
Это самый оптимальный вариант конкретно для нас, потому что вы сразу начинаете работать с дизайн-системой из агента.
Соответственно, контекст он понимает намного глубже, вы двигаетесь с ним постепенно и у вас нет каких-то лишних компонентов, чего-то лишнего, лишних стилей, токенов и прочего.
И это не создаёт лишний контекст, которым будет переполняться агент и тупить, тратить лимиты и так далее.
Второй вариант подходит, когда никто над тобой не стоит, не контролирует её, но всё-таки не хочется начинать с нуля.
Копируем готовые базы, переиспользуем их, используя уже другую директиву.
Но, если ты работаешь один, да, первый вариант лучше.
Если же у вас несколько человек в команде, то здесь вам больше подходит второй вариант.
Почему? Потому что, если каждый из вас будет создавать какие-то новые компоненты и ещё делать это одновременно, то появится несогласованность.
Ваши агенты будут обладать разным контекстом и не будут знать, что, например, какой-то компонент уже создан и будут делать его с нуля.
Да, можно создать взаимосвязанную систему, в которой всё это будет синхронизироваться, но это будет поедать много ресурсов, много ваших лимитов.
И сделать, чтобы это вообще работало бесшовно, удобно, просто, практически невозможно.
Ну и третий вариант. Вы работаете в компании, соответственно, вам нужно на её дизайн-системе что-то собирать.
Мы сканируем её полностью одним проходом, смотрим, какие есть назначения, какие есть компоненты, стили и так далее.
И уже отталкиваемся от этого при создании новых экранов.
Итак, я сюда уже закинул директивы. Давай начну с нуля через директиву DS-Baseline.
Закидываю её сюда, тут это можно убрать, и просто запускаю выполнение.
Давай откроем её и посмотрим, из чего она вообще состоит, пока агент думает.
В директиве Baseline зашит проверенный минимальный набор.
Один акцентный цвет, 9 нейтралов, 4 функциональных, Success, Warning, Eru и Info.
Типографическая шкала тут собрана на 9 размерах с Inter, 4 радиуса, 0,4,8 и 16 шкала отступов с шагом 4,8.
Тут плюс в том, что это не специализировано под какой-то проект собрано, это такая вот золотая вообще принятая база.
Возможно ты проводил уже тут исследование, возможно сразу с нуля хочешь приходить к практике, ну то есть в дальнейшем, когда будешь всем этим, то есть в дальнейшем, когда уже после обучения там унесёшь все эти директивы.
Я сюда зашил, чтобы он тебя брифовал, какое назначение у тебя, твои дизайн-системы, что ты хочешь собирать, чтобы кратко его вводными наполнить.
Он запускает первую фазу, бриф, и поскольку он уже обладает всем контекстом проекта, он этот бриф самостоятельно заполняет.
Какой у нас продукт, какая аудитория и так далее, поэтому мне делать это сейчас не нужно.
Он говорит, если все пять принимаешь, скажу окей, сохраняю, поэтому скажу окей, пускай сохраняет.
Главное, что директива сразу пишет variables прямо в Figma, двумя коллекциями примитивы и смысла, то есть семантические, и собирает 5-7 базовых компонентов, ссылающихся на смысловые variables, не на какие-то прибитые зафиксированные цвета.
Он, исходя из моей специфики отрасли, сам пытается придумать, что будет наиболее подходящим.
Тут уже на этапе брифа ты можешь сразу ему какие-то вводные закинуть, если они у тебя есть, либо после того, как он уже создаст эту небольшую дизайн-систему, что-то в ней поменять и сказать ему, у нас обновилось, посмотри, что именно, он все просканирует и внесет изменения сюда, обратно в агентскую среду.
Итак, директива полностью выполнена, у нас создалась новая папка дизайн-система, где появились два файла, бренд-бриф и фаундейшн.
Сюда по нашему бренду он сложил весь бриф, определил, что палитра у нас сдержанная, акцент холодный-синий, я в принципе так себе это и представлял.
Типографика, стандартная веб-шкала и так далее.
И второй файлик у нас фаундейшн, это уже более конкретизированное описание нашей дизайн-системы.
Конкретные кодировки цветов, какие в принципе нам нужны цвета, тут акцентный цвет он разбил на 5 оттенков, нейтральную палитру тоже серого, ну прям много так сделал, даже не знаю, нужно ли нам столько, ну пускай будет.
Функциональные также добавил сюда цвета, по типографике все размеры собрал, веса также у нас здесь есть, межстрочные интервалы, межбуквенные радиусы, отступы тени и слой 2, смысловые токены.
Здесь в общем все у нас есть, также есть конкретные привязки, primary, secondary и так далее.
В общем все то, о чем мы ранее говорили, это не интересно, давайте сразу это все закидывать в фигму.
Я своего агента перезагружал, поэтому MCP у меня отвалился, давай восстановим к нему подключение и продолжим.
Все, я ему написал, надо восстановить подключение сюда, закинул ему ссылку на фигма файл и он нам дает ссылку для авторизации.
Проходим аутентификацию, пишем ему готово, MCP восстановлен, продолжаю, foundation вы фактически согласовали.
Молчание.
Ну да, согласовал, так что можем двигаться дальше.
Так, переменные он создал, 49 примитивов, 25 семантических, идет в следующую фазу, создает foundation и 7 базовых компонентов.
Обратите внимание, каждый раз мне нравится это, что он делает скриншоты и проверяет, что он там насоздавал.
Ну вот тут уже видим маленько, что он создал эти foundation, давай не будем портить впечатление, сначала подождем, чтобы он полностью закончил и перейдем, посмотрим, что он там создал.
И еще одна ключевая важная особенность, он записывает node.id компонентов для ds.components.md, то есть он создает еще один файл components.md, в который записывает всю нашу как бы архитектуру фигмы.
Соответственно, у каждого компонента, у каждого там квадратика и прочего есть внутри фигмы свой id, мы его не видим, но он существует.
И здесь Клод создает, благодаря нашей директиве, компонентов.md, в которой прописывает, какие у нас есть компоненты, как они называются, какой у них id, какое у них назначение и какие есть варианты.
Это делается для того, чтобы, когда мы в следующий раз попросим его создать какую-то новую форму или еще что-то, он не смотрел сразу всю твою дизайн-систему и не искал, что ему для этого подойдет.
Нет, у него есть библиотека components.md, он знает, какие есть компоненты, по их названиям и назначениям может ориентироваться, что он может использовать, и затем через id обращается уже в фигму файли к конкретному компоненту.
Тут более того, расписан состав каждого компонента, из чего он состоит, какие у него заливки и так далее и тому подобное.
Это еще позволяет ему не только обращаться точечно и находить какие-то компоненты, но и запоминать в целом образ взаимодействия с дизайн-системой, то, как создавать новые компоненты.
Он уже видит, что должна быть такая структура, должна быть привязка к семантическим токенам, что у нас есть скругление цвета и так далее, все у нас задано, все у нас системно, аккуратно, какие у нас отступы и так далее.
И глядя на это, он не может просто создать какой-то новый компонент совершенно иначе, без привязки к семантическим токенам, без создания компонентов, с рандомными отступами и так далее.
Итак, он тут пишет, что он уже все создал, помимо этого создался у нас еще ряд файлов, Companions.md, Contract.md, это правила работы с дизайн-системой.
Здесь описаны общие паттерны того, какие у нас, например, на кнопках скругления используются, фоновые цвета и так далее.
И здесь также описан формат, что он как раз таки не может создавать какие-то рандомные новые объекты без привязки к дизайн-системе.
Он всегда должен опираться на нее.
И то же самое он делает с Cloud.md.
То есть, если у тебя уже есть Cloud.md, этим он дополняет его, если нет, он создает новые.
Опять же, смотря с какого этапа создания продукта ты зашел с этой директивой.
Все это предусмотрено.
Итак, давай посмотрим, что у нас получилось.
Во-первых, сразу скажу, у меня он создал в сайт-мэпе отдельно секцию и в нее все это дело положил.
Весь наш фундейшн и компоненты так быть не должно, но иногда он дает сбои.
Мы можем руками это все перетянуть, создать другие странички и ему обязательно сообщить о том, что у нас это все дело переехало.
Важности этого чуть позже поговорим.
Вот, например, у меня фундейшн страницы и что на ней?
Во-первых, он в понятный, нормальный, оформленный вид собрал вот все то, что он создал.
Все эти переменные, стили и так далее.
Вот у нас есть палитра, акцентные цвета, также уже привязанные к токенам.
Есть нейтральные цвета, функциональные и семантические.
У нас тут уже отмечены, есть несколько цветов.
Например, состояние успеха, состояние ошибки, то, на что нужно обратить внимание.
Цвет границы по умолчанию, текст полупрозрачный, muted, по умолчанию.
И surface action primary, то есть какие-то элементы, с которыми можно взаимодействовать, ну, в общем, залитые акцентным цветом.
Дальше у нас типографика, также у нас тут созданы все стили.
Стили у нас также тут сегментированные, heading, body, label.
Тут все это привязано, все это собрано.
И если мы сейчас углубимся в стиле, то здесь тоже можем увидеть, что у нас через переменные все это дело задано.
Также радиусы, 4, 8, 16 основные он создал.
И спейсинги, ну, в общем-то, тут больше ничего нет.
Да и в целом, не особо что-то еще нужно.
Кстати, если посмотрим на переменные, здесь также можем убедиться, что у нас есть примитивы, есть семантические.
Даже их количество он здесь указал, ну, хотя это, конечно, совершенно необязательно.
Примитивных у нас 49 штук, разные оттенки серого, разные акцентные цвета, разные размеры, xs, sm, xl и так далее.
Веса, трекинги, радиусы, скругления, отступы, короче, все, что душе угодно.
И семантические, точно так же здесь мы уже видим, что они привязываются к примитивам.
Все их называют по-разному.
Итак, тут у нас все работает, что у нас с компонентами.
Создал также ряд компонентов, тоже не буду обманывать, здесь я немного их поправил.
Тут, например, поставил просто fill, чтобы он переносил строку, да и больше ничего особо не сделал.
Ну и здесь мне больше понравилось, чтобы был автоспейсинг, а не фиксированный.
Это чисто вкусовщина.
В остальном он все сделал с первого раза.
Что у нас здесь есть?
Есть компонент с кнопками, три состояния у кнопки, также они здесь сразу описаны.
Вот, например, скопируем.
Тут у нас скругления заданы.
Вот эти отступы тоже можно было бы, наверное, через переменные задать.
Можно ему это указать.
Ну, можно этого не делать.
Цвет фона также через семантическую переменную, как и скругление.
Все.
Ну и здесь у нас описаны primary, secondary.
Все также семантики здесь соответствуют по названиям.
И даже тут у нас текст action отдельно семантический переменный собран.
Дальше email.
Также здесь два состояния нормальные и состояние ошибки.
Какая-то карточка сразу с нормальными текстами, нормальными placeholder, а не каким-то просто lorem ipsum.
Перезагрузить сервер.
Тоже дополнительное модальное окно.
Он собрал навбар, собрал разметку под иконку primary и secondary и состояние ошибок.
Мы также знаем, что у нас уже есть цвета под все эти состояния.
Здесь они также проставлены.
BG warning, BG error.
Вот только text muted.
Наверное, здесь отдельный нужен токен под цвет muted.
Текст здесь не очень корректно использовать.
Ну и зеленый также у нас проставлен.
Такая хорошая база.
Все, что дальше в этом файле появится, будет привязано к этому.
Уже мы будем здесь собирать расширенный UI kit, варианты, финальные экраны.
Все будет здесь и все будет работать на этой базе.
Поэтому давайте подытожим вот этот вот сценарий, из чего он состоит.
Нам позволяет все это проделать директива DS baseline и проходит она через три фазы.
Первое.
Пять вопросов.
Ну там за минуту отвечаем на них отрасль, аудитория.
Если ты делаешь не с нуля уже в контексте, ну скорее всего ты будешь точно делать это в контексте,
потому что мы движемся по урокам, то он сам запросто запомнился.
Заполнит этот бриф.
Тебя останется только подтвердить.
Второе.
Foundation MD.
Он собирает все потенциальные переменные, примитивные, смысловые.
Также учитывает, что если у нас кириллица, ты там это будешь указывать в брифе,
то немного другие нужны размеры текстом.
Все это сюда записывается, и ты делаешь свой approve, и после этого он идет в Figma.
Начинает с создания переменных, и потом начинает отрисовывать уже компоненты, foundation,
то есть все текста, разные блоки с цветами для демонстрации и так далее.
И второй вариант, сценарий B.
Мы стартуем продукт, и собирать с нуля не хотим.
Хотим сэкономить время, и хотим работать целой командой на уже готовой базе.
Где нам взять эту базу?
В Figma Community мы ищем Material 3 Design UI Kit, Carbon Design System, Gravity UI, Relume компоненты.
Тублируем свои черновики, и библиотека уже наша.
Дальше с ней работаем как со своей.
Сейчас продемонстрирую, как это работает.
Давайте сразу отмечу, какие библиотеки, ну прям такая база, которую можно использовать.
Во-первых, ShedCN UI Kit, это веб, она адаптирована под React приложение.
Это на самом деле сейчас, ну наверное, вообще самая актуальная библиотека.
На Reddit она упоминается вообще чуть ли не через пост.
Короче, популярная штука.
Мы сами ее используем в своих внутренних проектах, проектах для клиентов.
Отличная штука.
Огромная компонентная база, все собрано аккуратно.
Есть также свой MCP сервер.
Короче, штука классная.
Для большинства продуктов хватит с головой.
Также есть библиотека Material 3 от Google, кроссплатформенная.
Ну, платформенная, я думаю, о ней уже все слышали.
Но стоит учитывать, что она очень большая.
Там огромное количество предусмотренных взаимодействий, компонентов, прочее.
И если ты захочешь ее скормить своему агенту, то это займет время.
Также есть библиотека Carbon.
Она под B2B больше адаптирована.
Можно использовать ее.
Есть Gravity UI, это уже российский продукт.
И Relume, библиотека, которая больше ориентирована на какие-то готовые блоки под лендосы,
не под полноценные продукты.
Выбираем одну из библиотек, нажимаем дублировать к себе в черновики
и прогоняем DS Scan, вторую директиву, которая у нас есть.
Она сканирует полностью тот файл, который у тебя уже есть,
ту библиотеку, которая есть в нем.
Давайте посмотрим на примере, как это может работать.
Переходим в Figma, заходим в Community и здесь ищем название нашей библиотеки.
Я, например, возьму ShedCN, сюда ее введу.
Вот у нас ShedCA Design System.
Открыть Figma, переходим сюда и затем здесь скопировать.
Дубликейт копируем себе в драфты.
Я это уже делал, она у меня есть.
Поэтому после того, как вы это сделали, копируем ссылку на этот файл
именно после того, как вы скопировали себе в драфты
и копируем ссылку именно на драфт, не на исходник.
Он к нему полного доступа не имеет.
Возвращаемся после этого в наш проект.
Здесь, поскольку я уже первую директиву запустил и буду идти по ней,
я создам отдельное окошко.
Создал просто новую среду, test-chat.
Вообще ничего сюда не закидывал, кроме директивы DS Scan.
Закинул эту директиву и написал ему
«Используй директиву по этому файлу» и прикрепляем ссылку.
Все, он начинает сканировать,
начинает искать примитивы, компоненты, цвета, типографику.
Все это дело создает и формирует нам полноценный пул этих файликов.
Source MD.
Здесь в верхнеуровнево описано вообще, что у нас есть.
Далее, foundation.
Здесь уже всякие цвета, текста, какие у нас есть стили, подстили и прочее,
что можно там записать, например, в токен.
Какие у нас есть токены, если нет, то что туда можно записать.
Далее, компоненты.
Здесь уже более подробно расписано, что у нас есть свечи, слайдеры, тумблеры,
какие у них ID и как эти элементы найти.
Контракт и клод.
Позже поговорим подробнее, для чего эти файлы здесь создаются и как они работают.
Все, теперь, когда он полностью знаком с дизайн-системой,
когда он знаком с файликом, он может теперь с ней создавать новые любые объекты.
То же самое ты будешь делать со своей рабочей дизайн-системой.
То есть, что именно делает вот эта вторая директива DSCAN?
Она читает все токены, все, что у тебя есть и читает, какие есть компоненты.
Но читает именно верхний уровень страницы компонентов.
Он не зарывается туда, не смотрит вообще все.
И это очень важно, это прописано в директиве.
Почему?
Потому что если у тебя огромная дизайн-система на 300 компонентов,
то он просто захлебнется в таком объеме информации.
Поэтому двигаемся постепенно и итеративно.
И чтобы он не захлебнулся, также нам помогает индекс.
То есть, как я уже ранее сказал, у каждого элемента свой ID в Figma есть.
Агент держит в памяти не саму дизайн-систему, а ее компактную карту.
По карте понимает, какие компоненты есть, какие у них варианты, какие у них нод ID.
При сборке экрана читает карту, принимает решение и только тогда вызывает юз Figma с конкретным ID, чтобы вставить компонент.
И давай также честно рассмотрим, где это работает прекрасно, а где начинает сыпаться.
Работает прилично вообще на трех вещах.
Фундамент, то есть токены, типографика, радиусы, отступы.
Он с этим работает прекрасно.
Это не занимает у него огромное количество памяти.
Все это он сканирует, съедает и всегда с этим работает хорошо, как бы это оформлено не было.
Переменные Figma тоже.
Он видит прям целый готовый сразу каталог.
Ничего извлекать не нужно.
Он прекрасно с ними взаимодействует.
Также отлично он работает с простыми компонентами, с говорящими именами, заполненные матрицей вариантов.
Кнопки, импуты, карточки, модалки, какие-то табы.
Если все собрано аккуратно, это простые понятные компоненты с говорящими названиями.
Он прекрасно с ними работает.
И какие-то типовые экраны продукта, формы, списки, детали, дашборды по привычным схемам он собирает в 70-80% в случаях с первого раза.
А даже если что-то не так, то поправить совсем легко, там высоту какую-нибудь он поставит фиксированную вместо хак.
Ну, в общем, мелочи.
Сыпаться он начинает на больших корпоративных дизайн-системах.
Первое, это неочевидные имена, без описаний, без вариаций.
Ему сложно понимать, что такое, например, вот бэдж, чип, тег.
Они могут быть совершенно разными.
И если мы пользуемся этой системой каждый день, мы понимаем, что для чего.
Он же без говорящего названия может не понять.
Второе, это когда у тебя старое перемешано с новым.
Прежние версии компонентов лежат рядом со свежими, без моменток о том, что не устаревший.
Агент берет вообще первое попавшееся, ему все равно, что на его взгляд больше подходит, он то и будет брать.
Он не будет оценивать, это сейчас актуальная версия какого-нибудь компонента или элемента или нет.
Поэтому в этом плане тоже гигиену в своем проекте важно соблюдать.
Третье, паттерны композиции в Figma не хранятся отдельной сущностью.
Условная карточка, там, заголовком, картинкой, телом и кнопками живет в примерах, в главе того, кто с этой дизайн-системой работает.
В библиотеке же ее нет.
Такое тоже бывает.
И в этом случае догадываться, анализировать вообще все, что у тебя есть и искать какие-то баттерны, он, конечно, может.
Но у тебя уйдет на это огромное количество времени и ресурсы по лимитам.
Четвертый случай тоже часто встречается, когда дизайн-система разбита по нескольким файлам.
Конечно, хорошо бы это дело объединить, но в принципе можно ему ссылками скормить все.
Нюанс только в том, что эти базы должны быть синхронизированы с его пониманием твоего продукта.
А если что-то где-то меняется, а ты об этом даже не знаешь, то тут могут возникать такие узкие места.
Ну и пятое, это сборка автолейаутов.
Он прекрасно с ними работает, он умеет это делать, но иногда у него вот там, где нужно поставить хак и там, где нужно поставить фил, он ставит фиксированные значения.
Такое бывает, такое случается, но правится это в считанные секунды.
Вот.
Если ваша дизайн-система собрана аккуратно, описано, может быть, даже есть описание у ваших компонентов, устаревшее, помечено или убрано в отдельную страницу с архивом.
Есть также переменные, переменные классно, аккуратно структурированы, как сегодня мы это смотрели.
То, скорее всего, проблем у него вообще никаких не возникнет.
Он все это съест и будет прекрасно переиспользовать.
А еще со временем вы его дообучите, направляя, когда он совершает какие-то ошибки, и вообще будет все прекрасно.
Также отмечу, что если у вас сложная дизайн-система, какая-то там специфичная, есть разные нюансы, которые сразу могут быть непонятны.
Точно так же вы можете зайти в чатик, зайти в Components.md, там расписаны все вот эти компоненты, их назначения, и что-то отдельно прокомментировать, сказать ему, вот этот компонент для этого, тут у него такие есть нюансы.
Мы используем его там-то, там-то, там-то.
Точно так же можно создать еще файлик Patterns.md, и там просто описать паттерны того, какие экраны, например, у вас часто возникают, какие модальные окна и прочее.
Можете описать это туда, не обязательно даже делать это руками, можно закинуть ему скрины или объяснить на словах.
Он это все запросто интерпретирует в той форме, в которой ему в дальнейшем будет просто удобно с этим работать.
И еще один момент по поводу кириллицы.
Если вы пользуетесь не своей дизайн-системой, а вот такой, как ShotCN или от Google, то нужно понимать ряд вещей.
Во-первых, шрифт, который там используется, мы проверяем, что он отображает все наши символы.
Если нет, то сразу меняем, прежде чем успели там все на нем собрать.
Также межстрочный интервал у кириллицы выше, чем у латиницы на 3-5%.
Межбуквенный интервал должен быть немного больше, потому что на крупных заголовках кириллица плотнее латиницы.
И длина слов, просто нужно учитывать, что русские слова длиннее английских по ширине плюс 15-20% в среднем у нас получается.
Соответственно, если ты используешь библиотеку, которая изначально собрана на латинице,
то нужно понимать, что не везде у тебя все будет ровно и аккуратно.
Вот такие моменты могут возникать, это описано в директивах.
И еще одна вещь, без которой все, что мы сегодня делали, остается просто декорацией.
Это те самые файлы, контракт и clod.md.
Финальная фаза, каждый из двух директив кладет в проект два файла.
Контракт и clod.
Если, конечно, clod не было, если clod есть, то он его дополняет.
Это правила работы дизайн-системы.
В контракте прописан ряд правил.
Главное из них, это что при любой команде собери экран или добавь форму, дорисуй карточку.
Агент работает строго через эту дизайн-систему.
Компоненты только через UI-кит.
Цвета только через семантические прибитых каких-то кодов цвета быть не должно ни на одном экране, ни в одном компоненте.
Если нужного компонента нет, сначала добавляешь его в дизайн-систему, потом используешь на экране.
Если нет какого-то семантического токена, ты добавляешь эту переменную с привязкой к какому-то примитиву.
Дописываешь строчку foundation.md и только потом это все дело используешь.
Также там для него описан механизм синхронизации.
То есть предусмотрено, что ты что-то будешь править руками, что-то менять в документе.
И об этом не забывай сообщать агенту.
У него механизм синхронизации есть, он понятен.
Он проверит, что где изменилось и эти изменения в foundation.md внесет.
Ну и там в остальные файлы.
Ну и в cloud.md всю эту архитектуру, структуру описывают, чтобы когда я создавал новую сессию,
агент сразу понимал, что к чему, что где находится, по каким правилам мы здесь работаем.
Это позволяет нам синхронизировать то, что у нас в агентской среде и то, что у нас в фигме.
Создавая тем самым такую логичную, взаимосвязанную систему.
Ну и давай в качестве заключения еще по одной ошибке для каждого сценария укажем,
какие самые распространенные первые.
Для первого сценария он у нас такой достаточно свободный.
И здесь могут быть отхождения от дизайн-системы.
Он может сам что-то придумывать, создавать лишнее, начать забивать на использование каких-то там семантических токенов,
на их создание, на использование компонентов и так далее.
Здесь его нужно держать в узде.
Такое случается, когда его контекст переполняется, он фокусируется на других задачах.
Такое может быть, просто держим это в голове.
Второй сценарий, это когда у тебя уже есть компонентная база, есть целая дизайн-система,
и ты хочешь изменить какую-то мелочь, как-то ее чуть-чуть под себя подстроить,
а он начинает перекапывать все.
Здесь тоже нужно грамотно, точно формулировать, что конкретно ты хочешь изменить.
И третий сценарий, когда у тебя есть готовая дизайн-система, уже корпоративная,
то есть огромная, раздутая, сложная,
тут главной ошибкой будет просто закинуть ему ссылку на этот фиговый файл,
и сказать, вперед из песни, разбирайся.
Если эта дизайн-система огромная, так не получится, ему будет очень тяжело,
он съест все твои лимиты и потратит огромное количество времени.
Поэтому в таком случае мы работаем изолированно, указываем конкретно,
что вот страница с компонентами, изучи ее.
Лучше вообще начать со страницы Foundation, чтобы он разобрался со всеми токенами, переменными и так далее.
Но он и так по директиве DSCAN это делает.
Но лучше, в общем, изолированно ему указывать, с чего ему начинать.
И таким образом скармливать ему по частям твою дизайн-систему,
твою компонентную базу.
Сначала там какие-нибудь совсем простые импуты, кнопки и так далее.
И в дальнейшем, уже исходя из твоих задач, докидывать, докидывать, докидывать.
Если ты начнешь делать все и сразу, то он просто в этом захлебнется,
и ты потом, когда захочешь продолжить, не будешь понимать, что он точно запомнил,
какие компоненты он записал, какие нет, что есть в его системе.
Поэтому двигаемся постепенно, пониманием того, что с этой дизайн-системой
была проделана огромная работа и длилась она не один год.
Поэтому погрузиться ему полностью за раз в это, конечно, будет тяжело.
Итак, домашняя работа.
Тут на выбор у нас есть три сценария.
Во-первых, первый сценарий, который я советую вам делать,
если у вас уже есть какой-то небольшой проект, продолжать с этого,
использовать первую нашу директиву, которую я показывал.
Создать такой фундамент, маленькую базу с foundations обязательно,
с внесением всех токенов в стиле и рядом каких-то базовых компонентов.
Если же ты хочешь все-таки начать за готовые базы,
то имей в виду, что у тебя минимум должна быть подписка max5x.
Выбирай дизайн-систему, я советую.
Выбирай дизайн-систему, какая тебе на вкус и цвет подходит.
Используй ее, скармливай агенту, и можешь с ней двигаться дальше.
И корпоративная дизайн-система, если ты работаешь над своим личным проектом,
все сразу скармливать, я думаю, нам не обязательно.
В рамках домашнего задания достаточно скормить ему foundations,
чтобы он понял самую-самую базу.
И, возможно, несколько самых ключевых компонентов.
Опять же, импуты, ряд карточек, какие-нибудь placeholders и так далее.
Сильно не нужно нам сейчас проект раздувать.
У нас будет возможность это сделать на курсовой работе.
Там и времени у тебя будет дольше, чтобы все проработать,
чтобы подождать, пока откатятся лимиты.
Поэтому с тем же проектом из предыдущего урока двигаемся дальше.
И присылаем ссылку на Figma File.
На этом все. Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания и увидимся в следующем уроке.